all right George
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally from the city of El Monte
California
tell me about your family growing up uh
family growing up I was raised by my
grandma until I was about nine years old
and then uh myself and my sister were
raised by her and at about the age of
nine my mom came out of a Camp Pendleton
and she came back home and she picked us
up from Grandma's and uh
we started that roller coaster
my mom suffers from alcoholism
depression mental health issues and so
growing up with her through that stuff
was a little bit difficult and it
eventually kind of rubbed up rubbed off
on me
um at the age of 10 I Was Myself dropped
off at a mental health facility
what kind of stuff are you going to
um from from what I remember I was just
upset that
I left my grandma without you know any
control and and I was just depressed I
didn't want to live I just felt like it
was the end of the world living with my
mom at the time at 10 years old at 10
years old yeah so
I think what happened is my mom got
tired of me threatening to kill myself
that I was going to kill myself and uh
she eventually told me that we were
gonna go see a counselor
um and I you know I was with it whatever
I didn't really care and we ended up
going to see this counselor at a big
facility and I didn't think anything of
it
uh first thing they did was the
counselor showed me to the cafeteria it
was a nice buffet style cafeteria and uh
as I was eating my chicken thighs and
mashed potatoes and all that good stuff
I finished eating and I my mom and the
counselor weren't around me so I kind of
backtracked where the office was and I
found the counselor but my mom wasn't
there and it turned out that she left me
there
so uh I ended up being an inpatient for
at that facility about a year and then I
went to another facility for another
almost another year so and did you
connect with your mom again after that
um yeah we connected kind of like for
incentive reasons for me because I was
acting up so much in the facility
um my aggression was just
at its all-time high and I was just
fighting everybody I was a bigger kid so
I kind of had leverage on people
um so
so it was kind of an incentive for me to
act right and and and if I did I would
be able to see my mom so six months
later my mom came to visit me and it you
know of course I was excited to see her
and and uh you know when she left I
acted up again like I didn't want to be
there so
that that's where all my aggression and
my violence I think stemmed from
um you know later on in life and your
dad wasn't around
um no my dad he's uh he was a heroin
addict uh for his whole life he did like
two or three tours in Vietnam and uh he
was a Army Ranger airborne
and um
from the age of 17 he started dabbling
with heroin and he passed away in 2006
uh due to complications of hep C and
liver failure and that stuff so my whole
life he was he was in prison pretty much
um the most contact I had was
couple letters here and there
um
and uh when I was 14 I was able to go
see him he he's from the city of
Calexico El Centro area on the border of
Mexico and I went to go visit him and
he was just fighting his demons you know
and and I don't think it was probably
the best place for a 14 year old to be
um therefore you know I I my mom gave
him the chance to buy me some school
clothes and and we got all that out of
the way came back home and and he was
just kind of you know messing up so
um it was kind of crazy how I ended up
seeing him uh seven years later after
that I was smuggling
I was smuggling drugs from Mexico and I
my car overheated in the city of
Calexico right right after the Border
and at the time I had my four-month-old
baby in a car no I'm sorry two-month-old
baby in the car seat and my ex-wife
and uh it was like 120 degrees in
Calexico my car overheated I had 15
pounds of meth in the diaper bag
and I didn't know what to do so we got a
taxi to the gas station and at the gas
station I seen my dad
and at that time I I was going through
medical assisting school I wanted to be
a nurse and I knew what jaundice was and
I knew what liver failure was and Hep C
and the color that people turn
and I remember seeing him and he was
almost I almost didn't recognize him but
the way he looked at me I was like oh
[__] that's my dad and he ended up
giving me out of that little jam and uh
about six months later he passed away
um of liver failure but
but yeah that was the extent of my
relationship with my dad
um I and you know now now as a grown-up
I feel like I'm a lot like them other
than the heroin Addiction in what ways
uh you know just my dad had a big heart
my dad liked to help people everybody
other than himself
um my dad also didn't have a connection
with his kid which was me and I feel
like that's one of the
downfalls of my life now is my
connection with my kids is is very
minimal so I feel like that part is in
me uh you know part of my dad kind of
thing so
um but yeah I'm trying to work on that
and
and I'm trying to make my dad proud you
know and and and I feel like he's a big
guardian angel of mine because I've been
through the [__] you know and and I feel
like he's one of the ones that's getting
me out of things
or that has gotten me out of things so
with all your suicide threats as a young
kid were you ever diagnosed with like
borderline or anything yeah I was
diagnosed with uh severe depression ADHD
um add I was on Prozac as a kid
um I ended up I ended up stopping the
pros deck when I was 12. just my own
will like I I did it I didn't want to
take anymore I stopped taking the pills
and my mom's my mom realized that and so
she stopped filling the prescriptions
because it was money and blah blah blah
I was wasting them pretty much so
um after that I just uh I I don't you
know life was hard and I I never was
really happy with life
um and I really didn't care if I lived
or not you know and and and the way I
expressed that was my violence
um eventually I became from El Monte
Flores
which is like one of the biggest gangs
in L.A county and and I was just ready
to do whatever like I I had I didn't
really care you know like I wasn't
afraid to die I was kind of hoping to
die like I I was more on that side of
the perfect gang recruit yeah you know I
I was all in and
eventually I ended up getting shot five
times
um I got shot five times with my brother
uh which was also my homeboy they called
him gato from El Monte Flores uh he got
shot once and died instantly I got shot
five times and I lived uh we were in the
city of bacon on the way to Vegas
and um we ran into some enemy uh guys
and
and I got and we we got shot we got
jumped by like 25 guys and after that we
got shot so
that even though I was ready to die and
and I was ready to just give it up like
I had no problem with that even though I
had kids and all that like
at that point I I was faced with reality
and and I'd never had been so close to
God in my whole life like I never really
believed in him I it wasn't really
something on my mind but when I was
laying there
um I was asking my grandma who passed
away to help me I was asking my dad who
passed away to help me I was asking my
God like I was reaching out to all gods
I was at a point of of lowest of low and
what my brother dead next to me I I was
um
you know I was begging either to just
die already because I didn't want to
suffer
or I was begging to get me out of that
situation like I I really didn't know
and
and after that
um I was pretty messed up for a while I
missed the whole funeral I missed the
car wash I missed all that stuff and and
it just here I go back I I went back
into severe depression and my my way of
dealing with depression is aggression
um so you know after getting shot I
went to jail for putting a gun in my
kid's mom's mouth
um I bailed out of that and then right
after that I went to jail for running
over my mom's husband
um and then that one kind of stuck on me
I was fighting a attempted murder case
um a couple months later the SWAT team
got me I was still banged up from
getting shot here I find myself in super
max you know fighting to not go to
medical ward like I just wanted to be
with general population because you know
I had been in the medical ward in in the
Riverside County jail for for the uh
criminal threats and terrorist threats
on my kids why uh my kid's mom
and being in that medical award was
driving me completely insane because it
wasn't only people injured it was
mentally
people fighting with mental issues and
and yelling and it was just crazy so I
was fighting all I didn't care about my
sentence I didn't care about going to
prison for 20 years I didn't care about
anything all I cared about at the time
was being with the homies in general
population because that was
my only sense of family family and calm
like it was just different you know and
and you know while I was busted and
on my ninth month in supermax I ran into
this African-American dude
and which that was my changing point in
my life
um as I walked into the dorm after court
my mom was my mom was on the on the uh
stand testifying against me because I
tried to kill her husband my my sister
wrote a crazy statement against me like
my family was against me you know and
and I was again I was at the bottom of
the pit and I I didn't care I was the
first one and you know while I was in
custody to to engage in violent acts
amongst others and and you know my
homeboy was running the show there and
and I was I was just ready I was ready
to [__] somebody up with my cast you
know and and uh
when I ran into this African-American
dude um
it was kind of crazy because it was a
sense of calmness when I talked to him
uh he pretty much told me he was a
prophet of God and and he was there to
give me a message
uh mind you this guy
looked like he was in his late 70s uh he
looked like
he was homeless when he was on the outs
um it just looked like a rough dude and
and uh and he had so much stuff to tell
me
um mind you the the race card is heavy
in in custody so me talking to him was
like an act of God Alone
um
and when I was talking to him he was
just telling me so much stuff that
nobody should have known he told me
about the shooting he told me how many
kids I had he told me you know what I
had looking forward to he told me I had
a purpose here and if I didn't recognize
that God had a purpose for me that he he
said that God was going to pluck one of
my kids from this Earth so I know that
God was in control and and just crazy
stuff and after I talked to him
I really had a sense of reassurance that
everything was going to be okay
and it and it definitely was I ended up
getting out like after serving maybe
like 20 months
and um
here I was back on the streets uh I
found myself at the bottom of the pit
though um because of my I had a the
attempted murder was dropped to assault
with a deadly weapon with great bodily
harm
and um you know it was a high felony so
I couldn't get a job now I was I was
free from custody but now I'm I'm on the
streets with not not too much family to
to fall back on actually none at all
therefore now I found myself homeless I
was homeless for about four months and I
think what saved me through those crazy
times is just the fact that I wasn't a
drug addict and I wasn't addicted to
alcohol or any other that stuff which
gave me clear mind to really figure
things out you know and part of figuring
things out was
I reached out to a friend of mine who
was a lawyer
and I told them that I needed a job and
I couldn't find one I couldn't get a job
through a staffing agency nothing was
helping
and it was all because of my record so
what I had to do next is I had to filed
an expungement
um and because I was homeless and I was
on gr getting like 200 a month in in
food stamps and like a hundred and fifty
dollars in cash I was pretty limited to
how I was going to get that done so my
friend who was a lawyer he pretty much
gave me the
the plan on how to do it myself so I did
um I went to the Van Nuys court I
applied for an expungement and two
months later I got an expungement
granted by the judge and part of that
was because I wrote a page letter to him
telling them how
how I'm not a piece of [__] how I'm a
good person I just had some bad trying
times and and I you know I had gotten
through that and now I was ready to get
back into society and do something
positive and and you know I again I
think my my guardian angels and God
looks over me and and he expunged all my
record in All Counties so
here I am with the Clean Slate
I ended up getting a job with Time
Warner cable for a year after that I
found myself at the jet propulsion
laboratory working for NASA
um yeah so
all that stuff was proof to me that
there was someone looking after me
because mind you I'm working for NASA at
the jet propulsion laboratory which is a
Prestige facility Prestige organization
where people from all over the world
want to be there and want to work there
and here I'm a gang member from El Monte
Flores
with no high school diploma I just been
homeless not too long ago and I'm here
and I'm faking it you know and I'm
telling them that I know what I'm doing
and and and I'm not really doing a JPL
so I I was hired as a data data center
technician
um and the duties of that was you know
doing
the entry level configurations of
switches servers uh including installing
servers doing data center work
um very entry level and you had
experience at that no I didn't I had
barely just learned how to connect a DVR
working with TV with the Time Warner so
that's that's I would I would just
really think to myself like
what the [__] am I doing here at this in
this in this place you know and and
because of that I really had to prove
everybody wrong and you know it was
crazy I would I started saying good
morning to people and they would look at
me like put their purse on the other
side of them while we're walking through
the hallways like literally you know and
and here I I am you know I'm just uh my
boss was a a man his name was Paul
ottenfeld he was has 50 years of service
with NASA and he came to the US with 20
in his backpack from the Czech Republic
so
like his story was motivating to me
and therefore I felt like I had it like
given my all and nine years later I
ended up getting laid off
um just due to like the coveted stuff
and the budget cuts and stuff like that
so
I went out I I left JPL with the psy of
uh I proved myself I I ended up getting
the president's award I've gotten
different
um awards for service and for for
um you know good attitude and stuff like
that and I had I had I had a pretty
amazing experience being a gang member
from the city of El Monte at JPL it was
just it was just crazy so during that
whole time I found myself doing a bunch
of other stuff I found myself doing
background acting
um I was on a couple shows like the
Mayans SWAT music videos all kinds of
crazy stuff you know and and I felt like
my time at JPL was ending and my time to
motivate youth was starting
because I've been like out of trouble
for so long and I was working on my
portfolio because my belief was
when I was a kid people would tell me
not to be a gang member and I didn't
believe them because I didn't feel like
they knew what they were talking about
so now I'm a gang member I went through
all these hurdles in life I've been
through working for NASA acting
um I I'm a street vendor I have my own
fruit cart like all those aspects of
life and my experiences now I'm at the
point of my life where
I'm proving to the youngsters of what's
possible in life when you don't give up
you know because I feel like I wanted to
give up so bad back in my in my past
that now I'm so thankful that I didn't
because I would have never knew that I
would be doing interviews
um you know I have a interview that has
like 22 2.5 million views right now and
like 10 000 comments and all those
comments are like man we're so proud of
you
from Colombia where we're so proud of
you like just crazy stuff and it's and
it's all coming it's all making sense
now
my hard work and my dedication to just
being loyal and and just having a good
heart and helping people it's all coming
full circle now and it's obvious and
it's pretty it's pretty exciting how
many years has it been that you've
turned the corner
um I haven't been in trouble since
2005 was my last conviction
um I haven't gotten a traffic ticket for
like the last 10 years
um
I I've just I've just been staying busy
and and I really believe that job saves
lives and it saved mine um
any job that I've had I've always worked
hard which kind of kept me away from the
hood a little bit you know and it kind
of saved me that that just that little
bit of Savior that I needed was work
and now I find myself uh you know
motivational speaking to the kids at
challenge kids at-risk youth I work with
different organizations helping out the
homeless
um my passion is cooking so I I have a
friend by the name of Jacob with project
coffee cup and once a month we come and
cook for the homeless of Skid Row I cook
for people in my own neighborhood I do
backpack giveaway events in my own
neighborhood so
just life has just been so bright now
you know and I can't stress it enough
how glad and thankful I am I never
killed myself
um and I and and that's the reason I do
interviews and I tell my story because
I really feel like I was at the bottom
of the pit you know maybe not from a
drug aspect but mentally and just in
life alone like I was just done
and for those that are watching I just
really stress that
bad times are temporary and there's
always a a better day and you you can't
give up you know and I'm just again
thankful that I haven't given up and I'm
not giving up because there's a lot of
work to be done and I feel like there's
a lot of lives to be saved
did you feel loved when you were a kid
no I didn't
um
I just I I feel like you know my I love
my mom to to the death of me um you know
we have a great relationship today
um but I just feel like because she was
a single mom she had like three jobs at
any given time uh you know aside from
her drinking and you know her going off
on her own little on her own little
thing
but I just I just feel like life was too
busy to show us love you know what I'm
saying my mom was too busy
um and and I could just imagine now as a
parent I could just imagine how
heartbreaking it is to hear your 10 year
old son that he's gonna kill himself and
and you know and that that's why I I
I love my mom so much today because I
put her through the ringer
um and and you know she had a rough life
herself so I can't I can't blame her for
any anything you know and and that's why
I have such a
love and deep connection to people with
addiction is because my own mother has
fought with that for her own life for
her whole life along with my dad and and
being that I'm not an addict myself
um I can I can I know I kind of know
what they're coming from you know
because I I've seen it firsthand and and
I've seen what it what what it is
capable of and and I've personally been
afraid of that and that's what's kept me
sober um you know I smoke a little weed
here and there but
as far as like drugs and pills and and
alcohol like I just I have I have I have
something against that stuff and and
it's very personal so
um
yeah man I'm just I'm just thankful for
life I I'm I'm thankful that I'm still
good in my hood
um I'm thankful that I'm able to give
back to my own neighborhood
and it's pretty exciting to hear the
thank yous now because I never was told
thank you in my whole life I was never
told anything good it was always like
damn you're you're a [__] up you're just
like your dad this this and that and
nowadays it's hey you know thank you for
doing what you do
um I get messages all the time I just
got a message from a 19 year old two
days ago saying that he wanted to kill
himself because a girl that he had a
crush on unfollowed them on Instagram
like those are the things that we need
to change like these kids have no idea
how hard it can be and and we need to
share that that Mo that motivation and
share the positivity to these kids
because a lot of them aren't seeing it
all they see is negativity on social
media on the news and all that and they
feel like they have nothing to live for
and I feel like it as homies and people
that have made it through the [__] I
feel like it's our duty
to pass the positivity to these
youngsters to try to save them
because I don't feel like there's too
many people doing that these days it's
almost like we're waiting for these kids
to just erupt you know and we're just
watching it on on social media and news
and and we really need to I feel like we
really need to take a step and and help
saving these kids because
you know we need these kids they're our
future
you've been a gang member and you
climbed out and you work with
youth they're following a similar path
to you what do you think the the general
public doesn't understand about these
kids are joint gangs
the the general public doesn't
understand that these kids need to be
loved regardless of the fact that
they're gang members or you know on
drugs like I think that's the the reason
why us as kids want to give up on our
lives because we don't feel like we're
worth anything
um and and and that's why I've worked so
hard to
to prove that there is like at the end
of the tunnel and and uh I feel like
it's my duty because I've been blessed
enough to make it I feel like it's my
duty to pass that along and that's what
I'm doing I'm showing these kids that
just because you have a tattoo on your
face doesn't mean you're a piece of [__]
like it means you've made a bad decision
but we can't we can't uh I don't feel
like we should as adults and as older
homies I don't feel like we should down
these kids for their for their uh
choices I feel like we should just guide
them a different way
how important is self-worth in this
whole process oh man self-worth
self-worth is
self-worth is very important because
that's a that's that's one of the
biggest downfalls of these kids these
days is they have no self-worth that's
why they decide to shoot
that's why they decide to kill that's
why they decide just to get on one and
and do drugs for a week straight because
there's no self-worth and that I think
is the effects of
not being shown love because we're all
busy you know I'm saying as parents
we're busy we don't have time to always
stop our kids and say you know what I'm
proud of you keep doing great I love you
it's more like hurry up get your stuff
ready we got to go to school like it
there's no affection you know what I
mean if if it's
if we're at home and I've seen it
firsthand because it's happened in my
own home but
when my daughter was in high school she
would come home go to her room and be on
her phone same thing as myself I would
come home from work check my phone for
an hour or two and then here we are not
no communication and I think that's very
I think that's a very bad
um place where we get stuck is by you
know our phones and technology and this
and that because it takes away from that
Humanity that human to human interaction
and and I think that is what proves to
these kids how much love we have for
them versus a text message saying I love
you uh I think it's very important that
we need to tell our kids how much we're
appreciative of them how much we love
them and how much we're proud of them
and and I think just by those simple
dialogues with our kids like I think
that's life-changing and and I think
that's you know the the self-worth with
our kids is lacking
and spending real time with them yeah
real real time and you know that goes
back to the reason why I became a fruit
vendor on the streets
um my company is called push and fruits
La I named that because I used to push a
lot of dope I was a trafficker a lot of
years of my life and
and I wanted to get out of that so I
started pushing fruit and I think the my
choice to do that was so I can have that
human human contact I like talking to
people I like talking to strangers
um
I just like you know feeling someone's
uh you know
like their their presence bro like I
just feel like that's lacking these days
and I made it a point to sell fruit and
not only self-root and take an order but
talk to the person as I'm chopping their
fruit
um I I feel like I probably made a lot
of impacts on a lot of lives these last
five years that I've been selling fruit
on in different neighborhoods because I
know they remember me because I'm not
just a I wasn't just a fruit guy in the
corner with a language barrier that all
you do is just ask for what you want and
you get it and you leave like there were
people there would be people eating
their fruit and finishing their whole
bowl of fruit while they're still at my
stand you know and uh and that was the
whole purpose of it because I I want I
feel like my mission in life is not only
to bring motivation to these kids that
are giving up on themselves but to bring
Humanity back to us like it's not about
you know your phone and this and that
again like I said prior but I feel like
you know the human human contact is
lacking and and therefore things are
going crazy
what is the mentality of a young teenage
gang member
um their lives revolve around
everything's criminal everything's
violent for sure is it just that there's
so much testosterone going through their
blood that they can't control it
man I you know what I think I think
these kids these days and and when I was
a kid I think the whole gang
the whole thought of being a gang member
was just
I I it was it was Ultimate
um just because of the respect level
that it carries uh the camaraderie that
comes with it your homeboys that will
die for you
um I think these kids are so driven to
the gang life because
it's so much talked about
um I think especially here in in Los
Angeles County
um the gang is at its highest the gang
activity is like it was in the 90s and I
think these kids gravitate towards that
because of the adrenaline because of the
girls because of the money because of
the the publicity like all that stuff is
a factor and and unfortunately negative
wins you know and and negativity that is
shown throughout media is is gravity
these kids gravitate gravitate to that
and and they want to be a part of it
therefore they're shooting people on
live Instagram they're you know all that
stuff is is just out of being ultimate I
want to be that guy
I want to sell these drugs to the max I
want to be the you know the the killer
of the hood I want to be
uh the go-to you know what I'm saying
and all that carries weight uh you know
if you want to be the killer you got to
be the killer therefore these kids are
getting a rush out of killing people
because they have no worth you know if
you don't have self-worth you ain't
gonna care about the next person whether
it's your homeboy or a family member you
know they're it's just that
that that rush you know I I think a lot
of times these kids are also motivated
to commit crimes and to kill people and
to do some crazy [__] because a lot of
times they're under the influence I
think these kids are they have no
they have no chance because the math
the [__] pills all that stuff is
mind-altering to where you don't you
really don't give a [__] you know and
and these kids are already starting out
with the mentality if they don't give a
[__] with a little bit of glass and a
little Pookie action and and maybe a
couple lines like these kids are just
and they're gonna destruct and I think
that's what's happening on these streets
you know not only the pride of being a
gang member but
the lust over these drugs you know it's
so glorified and in all these songs they
talk about lean and they talk about
pills and blues and all this stuff
uh you know my own daughter was doing
pills in high school her freshman year
and she had no clue what the what what
the uh
she had no clue what was coming with
that addiction you know and thankfully I
kind of did a little scared straight
session with her and and you know it
came to the point where I had to pull a
gun on somebody because I I told her and
I had to prove to her that I was tired
of people taking advantage of my
kindness
and that whole plan that I had in my
mind was to scare the [__] out of her to
make her think that yeah I'm the change
dad you know but
I'm tired of people taking taking
advantage of my kindness which at the at
the moment I thought she was
I felt like she was taking advantage of
my kindness and My Love Therefore now
she was [__] up her life by doing
drugs you know what I'm saying and and
the only way I felt like I could cut
that was by showing her a little real a
little realistic situation that we can
be put in you know and and at the time
we were having this conversation in the
car some lady cut me off and her her
dude in the passenger side started
throwing gang signs on the freeway and I
was just looking like this is the
perfect time I'm gonna scare the [__]
out of this young kid and I'm gonna tell
her you know what you stop [__]
taking drugs you stop doing drugs
or imma get crazy like I'm gonna get
crazy and show you that you you know
there's a there there's a bad side of me
you know what I'm saying and and these
kids
thankfully it worked for her thankfully
she she got so scared that she was like
oh my god dad like you're [__] crazy
and this and that I said you know what
I am crazy but I try so hard
to be a better person to be a better
role model to be a better uh dad
but I said by you doing drugs and and
[__] nodding out while I'm talking to
you like that is unacceptable and it's
gonna stop right now
and you know what I it was a scary
situation but after that day she never
did she never did pills again and and I
really feel like that was a little
scared straight reality check for her
and sometimes these kids need that you
know and
and you know I'm not sometimes it's not
the best thing to do to you know uh make
a
make an example of a situation but at
the time being a dad I felt like that
was the perfect situation and I felt
like that was the best medicine for this
15 year old kid that thinks she knows
what she's doing
and uh and again thankfully it worked
and and I feel like unfortunately
there's a lot of kids that are stuck in
these pills these fentanyl all that
stuff is just it's just a different day
and and we just need to work harder to
uh to change the narrative to change the
narrative and to change the mentality of
these kids that that are just giving up
left and right
um right now the suicide rate amongst 10
year old
by the method of hanging is at its
all-time highest way of death amongst
kids like that the the
like if you go to the Morgan there's 10
10 10 year olds dead in the morgue
like eight of them are deaf by hanging
that shit's crazy
that that that's crazy and and you know
all that boils down to is we're not
showing love to our kids if anything
we're doubting them for their downfalls
and that's what we're focusing on
which is killing them I take your life
is much improved since uh it changed
from being
a man of violence and crime to being of
service to others yes uh and you know
what that ultimately that's my medicine
um my medicine to this day you know
because I still deal with depression I
still deal with those those dark demons
in my mind especially when I have a lot
of downtime but my medicine is helping
others like
um if it's
cooking a bacon wrap hot dog for a
homeless guy on Skid Row that's medicine
to me if it's you know I I do a lot of
outwork uh Outreach work for the
homeless people because I feel a
connection with them because those are
the realest humans on earth like I feel
like our homeless Society is they have
nothing to prove you know and I feel
like being that they have nothing to
prove I feel like they're the most
genuine and and that that
genuine love and genuine
thanks comes with food and and I feel
like you know I I try to help as many
people as I can because when I'm feeling
down that's the only thing that helps me
feel like I have purpose and like I have
um
like I have something to live for you
know and and I feel like I'm doing a
good job at it and and you know when I
have a dark moment I think about the
good things that I've done and the good
things that I'm doing and that brings me
back to okay keep keep it pushing you
know keep keep it going
because uh depression is a real thing a
lot of people think it's [__] um and
I can I've been through it my whole life
since the age of 10 and I can honestly
say that it's
it's a real thing it can really knock
you down but I think
I think a big thing of keeping it going
is staying motivated and staying
determined to be alive
um
and and this is perfect proof uh I
worked so hard for the last
I don't know 15 years to prove to people
that life is worth not giving up on and
I feel like
I feel like I'm doing a good job at it
and I and I have people that have
reached out to me and I have been able
to talk to and make them realize that
their life isn't the only one that's
[__] up like my life's [__] up your
life's [__] up but
the way we get through it is by not
giving up
and I think there's there's nothing
impossible and I think every bad time is
temporary and I think with determination
and motivation to be a better person
there will be a brighter day for sure
tomorrow
all right George thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you man thank
you for having me and and I appreciate
your time very inspiring thank you